[Musik]
nur
kelek schade die
werkstätten hier ruht der mir jetzt zu
mir du
zeitung lesen wir schauen auf
die subvention gewaltigen druck zur
blüte im schädel
grund ist
dass gott sei dank ich halte dieses
theater nun gern länger als ein paar
sekunden aus richtig voll werden und
dieses auf optimierte rollen weiter da
noch dieses ekelerregende mir was wäre
die welt mein freund ohne einen gut
gekühlten
höllental apropos höllental hast du im
feuilleton die rezension gelesen über
den urfaust im residenztheater leider
noch nicht robert aber bitte
hans ich zitiere die mit spannung
erwartete inszenierung des gefeierten
regisseurs hans martin broiler waren
gestern in den heiligen hallen des
münchner residenztheater stadt die
vielen vorschusslorbeeren wurden nicht
umsonst verteilt der abend wird den
zuschauern wohl noch lange im gedächtnis
bleiben um dies nicht nur aufgrund der
äußerst intelligent südwestdeutsche
zeitung gut zu wissen bevor du weiter
sprichst geschätzter freund mich fristet
möchtest du vielleicht einen kassenhit
100 in kürze sehr sehr gern